[Música]
y
muy bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 en esta
oportunidad nos acompaña emilio archila
el ex consejero presidencial para la
estabilización y la consolidación
estamos hablando de uno de los
principales encargados de lo que es la
implementación del acuerdo de paz que
fue alcanzado en el año 2016 entre el
gobierno de colombia y la ex guerrilla
de las farc un acuerdo que muy pronto va
a cumplir cinco años un cargo que está
desempeñando desde que comenzó el
gobierno de iván duque que precisamente
cumplió recientemente tres años señora
chila primer lugar muchísimas gracias
por su presencia en france 24 como
estaba comentando al principio de la
entrevista se están cumpliendo o se
acaban de cumplir mejor dicho tres años
del mandato del presidente iván duque
qué balance hace de la implementación de
los acuerdos de paz durante todo este
período
muchas gracias santiago muchas gracias
por esta invitación por el interés que
todos siguen teniendo en la
implementación de este acuerdo que como
ha sido dicho por tantas personas es un
ejemplo para el mundo que seguimos
necesitando mucho más ahora de cara a lo
que está ocurriendo en en afganistán y
permítame responder su pregunta no n no
en mis palabras sino en palabras de dos
instancias en las cuales de hecho
participa directamente de francia
el consejo de seguridad de las naciones
unidas tiene muy pocos temas en los
cuales se permanece unido donde todos
los miembros todos los embajadores están
de acuerdo y uno de esos ha sido el
continuará clamando la manera como el
presidente duque está llevando a cabo la
implementación y la segunda voz aún más
ilustrada más conocedora es la de la
embajadora patricia de lombard que la
semana pasada
estando con el presidente le decía que
este es un caso de éxito que le decía
que europa en palabras de ella en muchas
oportunidades ha exportado de guerra que
ahora quieren formar parte de procesos
como el es el colombiano y que podemos
contar con que esta orientación que le
ha dado el presidente eduque los inspira
a continuar con nosotros
ahora sí bien usted es manifiesta que
para muchas personas esto es un ejemplo
no desde algunos sectores hacen ciertas
críticas señalan por ejemplo que hay
ciertos retrasos en lo que es la
implementación de los acuerdos apuntan
por ejemplo a que quizás se han enfocado
más en lo que es la reincorporación de
excombatientes y quizás postergaron
otros factores no como la reforma rural
integrada la sustitución de cultivos
ilícitos que le responde usted señora
archila
los hechos santiago en los hechos son
los que hablan por él por nosotros en el
programa de sustitución voluntaria de
cultivos tenemos en este momento
100 mil familias estos son 400 mil
colombianos que gracias al apoyo del
gobierno han dejado la coca y que ya
están en la etapa de estar iniciando la
implementación de esos proyectos
productivos 400 mil colombianos es
posiblemente una capital intermedia en
colombia en materia de
desarrollo rural los planes de
desarrollo con enfoque territorial esa
es la estrategia para estabilizar
170 municipios los más afectados por la
violencia y la pobreza en colombia esta
es la tercera parte de nuestro
territorio de eso es el 20 por ciento de
nuestra población y hoy en día después
de haber escuchado las voces de las
comunidades estamos desarrollando lo que
ellos nos pidieron con una inversión ya
de 9 billones de pesos 9 billones de
pesos es fácilmente el 70 por ciento del
valor de la primera en el metro de
bogotá
tenemos en implementación el catastro
multipropósito tenemos en este momento
el banco de tierras que debería haber
llegado a tres millones de hectáreas en
15 años con más de un millón doscientos
mil hectáreas que luego en cualquiera de
los frentes las las cifras hablan pero
nos hablan por sí mismas según archila
vamos a hablar ahora de un elemento muy
importante que tiene que ver con la
violencia en colombia aunque bueno las
cifras oficiales y las de diversas
organizaciones de derechos humanos
difieren por supuesto como es habitual
es un hecho que la violencia contra
líderes sociales también defensores de
derechos humanos ex combatientes y
determinadas comunidades no se detiene
en el país este año por ejemplo hasta
julio de acuerdo hay de paz y estamos
hablando de el instituto de estudios
para el desarrollo y la paz han sido
asesinados 103 líderes y 31 firmantes
del acuerdo y que ha habido 60 masacres
con 221 víctimas mortales
el país en el país está lejos de
detenerse no lo que es la violencia que
se está haciendo ante este escenario
santiago la idea de que la violencia
detenga querría decir que hubiera cero
muertes y dice obviamente es el
propósito del gobierno es del propósito
de todos pero permítanme poner algo de
contexto que puede ser ilustrativo lo
primero es que en el proceso de
reincorporación tenemos un poco más de
13.000 ex combatientes esos son más o
menos mal contados el equivalente de la
totalidad de las personas que están en
otros grupos armados hoy en día
como como resultado de esta
implementación como resultado de esta
implementación la manera como lo han
descrito
en el consejo de seguridad es que
colombia hoy en día es mucho mejor país
y para eso es importante tener en cuenta
que antes de que se iniciara la
implementación de las cifras de
homicidios eran inmensamente superiores
las de secuestros eran inmensamente
superiores las de minas antipersonales
también las de ataques terroristas
también el número de niños que eran
reclutados ilegalmente luego siendo que
el objetivo de cero si uno mira lo que
ocurría antes de que se iniciara el
proceso y hoy hemos disminuido
sustancialmente
el otro factor que puede ser relevante
es que
cuando se firmaron los acuerdos con las
antiguas guerrillas de las farc
ln ya existía el vélez ya existía el
clan del golfo ya existía los caparrós
ya existían los contadores ya existían y
a todos esos se les sumaron las que hoy
en día conocemos como las disidencias
luego la idea de que la implementación
de los acuerdos era en sí misma
suficiente para lograr una paz estable y
duradera nunca fue nada más distinto que
une headline nosotros tenemos que ir
avanzando como estamos avanzando en la
implementación de los los acuerdos para
aprovechar esa oportunidad de resolver
tantos temas de fondos sustanciales
profundos que debimos haber solucionado
hace hace décadas y al mismo tiempo ir
resolviendo esas otras fuentes de
violencia luego siendo que nuestro
objetivo es llegar a cero
hoy en día colombia son mucho mejor país
que hace tres años
ahora otro tema clave también en este
contexto y sobre todo si tenemos en
cuenta lo que debe ser la reparación es
el de los 'falsos positivos' durante los
años de conflicto armado que dejan una
gran deuda en el país aclaremos porque
tenemos una audiencia internacional que
estamos hablando de lo que son los
asesinatos de civiles cometidos por
militares para hacer pasar esas muertes
como bajas de guerrilleros en combate y
las fuerzas de seguridad volvieron hace
poco a estar en el centro de denuncias
de violaciones a los derechos humanos me
refiero durante las manifestaciones
antigubernamentales no en el marco del
paro nacional que dejaron decenas de
muertos denuncias de uso excesivo de la
fuerza inclusivo de agresiones sexuales
contra manifestantes como cree usted que
se ve afectada a la legitimidad de las
fuerzas
pero l
ese es un es un tema que obviamente
tiene que ver que apenas indirectamente
con la implementación de los los
acuerdos pero respecto del cual puedo
señalarlo los siguientes el gobierno del
presidente duke ha estado más que atento
siempre a escuchar todas las
manifestaciones pacíficas de parte de
cualquier persona que haya estado
protestando como usted sabe santiago yo
fui designado en el liberty y la
conversación con el comité nacional del
par
una vez que iniciamos la conversación
con el comité nacional del paro al mismo
tiempo tuvimos el diálogo con las
víctimas de la violencia y con ellos
logramos un acuerdo en 10 días tuvimos
diálogo con los jóvenes que son víctimas
y con ellos tuvimos acuerdo tuvimos
acuerdos regionales en por lo menos 12
zonas del país donde las mesas eran
regionales lo mismo ocurrió con los
diálogos con las juventudes y s
estuvimos cerrando ese diálogo hace dos
semanas con representantes de por lo
menos doce mil reuniones que hubo en ese
respecto
en relación con con las protestas yo
creo que colombia salió como país
democráticamente
fortalecido de esos sucesos en la medida
en que para nosotros para todos los
colombianos no solamente el gobierno hoy
en día es claro que distinguimos entre
la protesta pacífica que se acoge que se
escucha que se le brindan todas las
garantías al colombia rechaza hoy en día
las todos los bloqueos que generaron
tanto desabastecimiento tanta pobreza
tanta inseguridad y de otra parte un
rechazo unánime en cabeza inclusive del
del presidente o liderada por el
presidente para aquellos casos en donde
existan excesos por parte de la fuerza
pública
ahora con varios focos de conflictos
abiertos no presencia de guerrillas como
lln en grande el golfo el pl cientos de
líderes sociales y ex guerrilleros
asesinados cada años manifestantes que
como decíamos mueren en protestas
sociales que están cerca general china
está colombia de alcanzar finalmente la
paz
la paz es una es de s s empleamos un
concepto que hay puede muchas formas de
definirlo una de esas es definirlo como
la ausencia de la ausencia de violencia
colombia en lo que tiene que ver con mis
responsabilidades
en esos cinco años logramos que
quienes estaban en armas hoy en día
estén en el congreso de la república
tienen garantizadas sus curules
adicionalmente la semana pasada el
presidente sancionó las 16 curules
adicionales para clase para las víctimas
y el partido de los comunes que es el
resultado de las farc participó en las
elecciones locales más pacíficas que ha
habido en 60 a 60 años en el caso de
irlanda se demoraron 10 años en entender
que eso era necesario
y tuvieron que volver a abrir sus
acuerdos para abrir ese espacio
democrático colombia dentro de estos 5
años creo la justicia transicional que
se ocupa entre otras cosas de los
'falsos positivos' que usted mencionó
tenemos los 13
pilares de la justicia transicional
funcionando luego el tiempo está
previsto para una implementación de 15
años pero vamos en el camino correcto
emilio archila muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24
muchísimas gracias a ustedes y muchas
gracias al pueblo francés gracias
nuevamente a nuestra audiencia le
invitamos a continuar informándose en
france 24 y en france mit y cuatro.com
[Música]